[Music]
they've played fast and loose with
Batman cut Superman down to size and
sent Wonder Woman To The Cameo zone now
DC is shrugging a made for Max film into
theaters while their Universe Burns as
their newest hero shows up to a party
after the host shat on the couch and
send everyone home banito of
Festa Blue
Beetle meet a hero who is definitely
still canonical even though this movie
isn't as you welcome the most beloved
Latino hero of all time to your screen
George Lopez is that the new time I got
you he's Rudy the only conspiracy-minded
Uncle to somehow Dodge qanon so if you
made him the Blue Beetle this would be
10 times more interesting Batman's a
fascist but instead we'll settle for
cobra Zolo maridia he's at the magical
time in a new star's life between their
first starring role and their first set
of veneers as he takes on the part of
haime Reyes a good kid from the wrong
side of GTA Vice City does anybody in
this town know how to
drive okay okay okay oh my
God everything will change when he
contracts a mean case of superhero
origin story symptoms of which may
include itching so itchy
this thing
burning oh my God I'm on fire and weird
boners hey guys are POS the nothing
happened her mom
died I feel a surge of blood rushing
towards your mid
region because his body's been hijacked
by the Blue Beetle an alien suit that's
just as deadly and effective as a
fighter jet controlled by your Alexa
engaging threat
engage got you do something testing
acceleration systems do fast do fast HST
overreacting you kid at me all right C
activate rebooting
rebooting are you kidding me together
they could search for where the Blue
Beetle came from why it's on Earth and
why it chose haime as its host or they
could just not do that you don't
actually care about Blue Beetle do you
they don't what the H is Blue Beetle
like Superman Metropolis with a flash in
Central City but just uh not not as good
H it's kind of a let down if you need an
actress to fall in love with a guy
pretending he's in terrible pain you
call Neymar's X
[Applause]
Neymar Bruna marzini is Jenny cord she's
a billionaire nepo baby on the board of
her daddyy CGI Army Factory but if she
were running things they'd be a charity
honest it's not about taking from the
community but giving back to the
community watch her play hide the Big
Blue Beetle box from Susan sandon's
Victoria a super villain who's
contractually obligated to do at least
one racism per scene Dr Sanchez hello
actually that's not my name I will have
a cigar they're made by real Cubans
anday and who got her degree from the
same grad school as Dr Evil don't get in
my way Jennifer Target the family they
could kill him oh bummer we can learn a
lot more if we take it off his corpse
she's so evil the only explanation that
makes sense is if a bunch of dalmations
Dro kicked her mom off a cliff as a
kid have you seen Spider-Man Iron Man
Venom andman or Shazam then you get it
it's one of those take your pig you're
becoming symbiotic what's different is
it celebration of all things Mexican
amican from on the nose references like
tacos and the Virgin Mary to more deep
Cuts Like ches burito or having at least
one emo relative that pulls off the rare
feat of making you care more for the
unpowered background characters then for
the hero villain action or backstory
look it's not a bad film but we just
watched 30 superhero origins in the last
10 years you going have to drop more
than bug farts on us to break out take
that so strap in for a zany fun super
hero Adventure that's maybe the 1,000th
movie to end up with two guys in
identical suits fighting but still makes
the most out of a solid cast I deserve a
luxury dump right now all right a great
score and a promising young director and
who knows if enough people watch it on
streaming maybe it will get a sequel
after all dad is alive Ted cord is alive
see Ted cord's alive Ted cord he was the
original Blue Beetle well kind of he's
the one that found the scar but it was
actually a professor named Dan Garrett
who the suit chose is hey where you
going starring hi may I be your Iron Man
Jen things you'd never expect to hear
five-time Oscar nominee Susan sandon say
out loud without the Scarab we can't
complete the OM carac ready to claw the
Scarab chose you but it belongs to me
show me the car packs Simba you have
forgotten me Miss lorville Greg guara
what we do in the lab coats and Uncle
trucker
a bug
Strife so Blue Beetle is one of those
Heroes who won't kill no killing he
should really tell that to the rest of
his family it's like a can't
miss hey look Mom I got the Honest
Trailers guide to read my sentence I
will say anything for love but I won't
say that how many zombies could Rob
Zombie Rob if Rob Zombie could Rob
Zombies sometimes I have trouble
controlling the volume of my voice